So we're following the growing story of Donald
Trump, allegedly with holding 200 and
the million dollars in military aid from Ukraine
because Ukraine appears not to have followed
through with Donald Trump's request that they
investigate and smear Joe Biden for the benefit
of Trump in 2020, which in and of itself is
a massive scandal.
Um, and what we now have are videos of both
Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump being asked
about this.
We'll start with Giuliani.
We'll go to Trump a little bit later on.
So Rudy Giuliani is invited onto CNN with
Chris Cuomo.
And within it, this is within a one minute
segment, but the contradiction actually happens
within about 25 seconds.
Uh, Rudy Giuliani first denies and then immediately
admits to asking Ukraine to investigate Joe
Biden's.
So as you probably are familiar with at this
point, every time something like this happens
in initially, there's just a blanket denial
from Trumpists.
Uh, and even, even though very often the Trump
administration will not, uh, formally make
a denial, but then individual elements start
to be acquiesce to Rudy Giuliani here and
Donald Trump later.
So this is all the same one minute clip.
Rudy Giuliani denies that they did this.
Then says the opposite and admits that of
course they did.
They didn't investigate Joe Biden.
No, actually I didn't.
I asked the Ukraine to investigate the allegations
that there was interference in the election
of 2016 by the Ukrainians for the benefit
of Hillary Clinton for which they were already
as a morality.
Anything about Hunter Biden?
You never asked anything about Joe Viola.
Anything I asked about Joe Biden is to get
to the bottom of how it was that who'd Sankoh
who was appointed dismiss the case against
Antiga did ask Ukraine to look into Joe Byte.
Of course I did.
You just said you didn't know.
I didn't ask him to look into Joe Biden.
I asked me to look at the allegations that
are related to my client, which tangentially
involved Joe Biden in a massive bribery scrutiny,
not unlike what he did in China.
Rudy, you explained to me how the kid got
one point $5 billion from, I have no [inaudible]
patients, but just be careful about what you
say.
I asked you [inaudible] to look at Joe Biden,
you said No.
Then you went on to say that you did that.
You know I didn't support it.
What I said was this, I asked them to investigate
the allegations that relate to the false charges
against the president of the United States.
Those allegations tangentially involve Biden.
So your answer should have, let me finish,
Chris,
let me finish.
I didn't ask you crane anything about Biden
other than of course, I asked them about these
three things related to Joe Biden.
It's getting to be that crisp season here
in New England that comes after the summer,
which we call the season for treason and lies.
Anytime that Rudy Giuliani is involved, and
it's actually even worse than Rudy Giuliani,
but just denying and then admitting this,
Rudy Giuliani in that clip denies it, then
admits it and immediately denies having denied
it just 25 seconds before.
And the the, the saddest and the most tragic
part of this all is that this is convincing
to many trumpets.
There are Trumpists who hear the allegations
and of course they're primed with quote fake
news as a meme.
They immediately are primed to say, this must
be fake, this must not be real.
And they start climbing around the internet,
desperately looking for some way out of a
room that has no exits.
Quite frankly.
They want some defense, they want some clarification.
So then Rudy Giuliani goes on CNN and says,
oh, I never did it followed by, of course
I did it followed by, I never denied doing
it even though he just denied doing it 25
seconds earlier and Trump is see it and they
say, David, David, David this didn't you see
Rudy Giuliani on Chris Cuomo.
He already explained this entire thing.
He did a great job.
See, Rudy cleared it all up.
It's just another one of these fake news smears.
And unfortunately we were working actually
on a long form piece about what I call the
Knowledge Pyramid, which is that you have
all these people commenting on the top of
the Knowledge Pyramid, which is day to day
news with no knowledge foundation.
They lack all a, a knowledge of epistemology
and critical thinking and news literacy, media
literacy and subject matter knowledge.
So they just appear and they see what's at
the top of the pyramid, the sort of junk food,
the day to day occurrences, which out of context
don't really tell you anything.
And that's how you end up bamboozled into
thinking, hey, look, Rudy already cleared
this up.
There's absolutely nothing here.
So that's Rudy Giuliani's, commentary, denial,
uh, acceptance, and then a denial of the denial
that just happened.
Let's next talk about Donald Trump being asked
about all of this.